we know that ice is melting as the world
gets
warmer but new data shows it's happening
more quickly than even scientists feared
since 1994 three uk universities have
been tracking
ice levels using satellite images of the
planets poles
mountains and glaciers and they've
described their results
as staggering this is the first time
anyone has looked at all the ice that is
disappearing across the world
it's estimated 28 trillion tons of ice
has been lost in less than 30 years
to put that into context that would be
enough to cover the entire
united kingdom in a sheet of ice a
hundred meters
or 328 feet thick
and the scientists say their findings
are further evidence
of the catastrophic damage caused by
greenhouse gases
it can be a little doubt now that it's
um is global warming linked to climate
emissions that
um the surface temperature of the earth
on average has risen by
about one degree since um 1880 this is
exacerbated in by the poles due to
reductions in albedo and how the planet
redistributes heat
and energy and what we've seen is the
planet's eyes
reacting to the warming of both the
oceans and the atmosphere
the ice study follows a recent report
which concluded
a heatwave in siberia would have been
almost
impossible without climate change
[Music]
across the world more extremes of
weather are being experienced
even in the uk what we now see as a
heatwave
will become much more of a common summer
time event
over the next 30 years as the planet
continues to change
because of global warming lisa holland
sky news